more hopeful news in the fight against
covid19 drug maker moderna says its new
vaccine is
94.5 percent effective in
phase 3 trials last week pfizer said
its similar version of a vaccine had a
90 percent efficacy rate the governor
says both pfizer and modern vaccines
will be free both require two doses
health experts say there will likely be
doses for some high-risk people by the
end of the year and then widespread
distribution
by spring of 2021. now las vegas played
a very important key role
with the newest vaccine from moderna
some southern nevadans volunteered to
participate
in that trial joe moeller spoke to a man
who says he really wanted to help with
the fight
joe well hundreds of people here in
southern nevada participated in this
vaccine trial that is still
ongoing now as these cases continue to
go up many companies are eager to get
this vaccine out to the public
today i spoke to michael burton he is
also a lawyer burton is participating in
the moderna trial in july he heard the
company was looking for volunteers
he went in for two different rounds of
shots and had blood work done
half of the volunteers were given a
placebo while the others were given the
actual vaccine
with today's good news of the
effectiveness of the vaccine burton
hopes this can
save lives i never had any side effects
at all even from the injection itself
which
i usually do get some bruising and
whatnot but i didn't have
i had nothing basically no no
actual side effects and no physical side
effects
i received a statement from michael
levin and vaccine investigator wake
research
was overseeing parts of this trial in
the area it says in part we are thrilled
that our las vegas team and the
volunteers in our study who i consider
heroes were able to contribute we
continue with the study protocol which
at this time consists of collecting
samples of blood and serology
studies now a medical expert i also
spoke with today says
so far next here the fda has to review
the data from
moderna moving forward and he hopes that
in the next few weeks
perhaps before the end of the year that
uh frontline workers will be able to use
this new vaccine
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now